sur les boulevards d'orléans métropole
les cyclistes dispose désormais d'une
voix rien que pour eux c'est un des
rares bienfaits de la pandémie
je vais dire qu'on vit déjà arrangé pas
passé avec un profil les revoit les 7 km
de voies dédiées aux vélos le resteront
le conseil métropolitain a pris la
décision de les pérenniser les cyclistes
les ont adoptées avec des axes
privilégiés comme celui du pont george 5
dont plus personne ne semble pouvoir se
passer sur cet incident hier notamment
le pont royal où nous sommes aujourd'hui
on a assisté à des augmentations de
circulation vélo de pratiquement 70 % ce
qui est énorme
on s'aperçoit que effectivement ça
correspondait réellement à une attente
et un besoin alors les comportements
aussi des gens ont aussi été modifiés
parce qu'un certain nombre de personnes
qui ne pratiquaient pas le vélo
aujourd'hui sont amenés à le pratiquer
pour diverses raisons
il s'agit maintenant pour la métropole
de rendre les pistes plus visibles de
les sécuriser
et bien non j'ai pas fait attention ça
va bien 5 millions d'euros ont été
votées pour l'aménagement du réseau
cyclable une mesure inédite pour le
budget métropolitain
si on compare à d'autres métropoles de
taille comparable non c'est pas
particulièrement énorme j'ai envie de
dire c'est nécessaire sur ce type dax la
très circuler il faut absolument des
aménagements en site propre donc de type
piste cyclable donc où les usagers sont
en sécurité séparé du trafic automobile
donc la sueur sur ce genre bac c'est
indispensable et ça ça justifie des
investissements lourds justement et
d'une manière générale dans la métropole
développer les itinéraires rapide et
sécurisée entre les différents pôles
d'activité
les travaux de renfort de signalisation
vont débuter cette semaine la
construction du réseau lui devrait durer
plusieurs années
après des décennies consacrées au tout
voiture